Hörrni, fan vad kul alltså.
Vi har BlackWave bakom oss, det känns skitbra, nu kan vi andas ut lite grann.
Så vi börjar med det bara.
Skönt.
Hörrni, ja just det, du filmar så jag måste ju sätta mig.
Viktigt för livestreamen.
Hej och varmt välkomna till Dagens Kitchen Commerce här hos Juni på Katarinavägen Nio i Stockholm.
Det är den fjärde december idag, år 2024.
Och vi sitter i Junis helt fantastiska lokaler här i Stockholm för att diskutera digital handel, inte i år utan nästa år, år 2025.
Vi kommer prata om strategi för tillväxt, strategi för lönsamhet.
Vi kommer prata om en teknik driven transformation som pågår just nu, främst drivet av AI.
Men innan vi gör det här så kommer vi såklart blicka tillbaka på 2024, hur har det gått?
Och framförallt kanske hur har Black Week gått under året?
I panelen idag så har jag med mig två fantastiska personer, båda har varit med i podden flera gånger.
Det är sjukt, sjukt kul och de har ju många, många års erfarenhet från just exakt det här.
En varm applåd för Joel Lövenberg, vd på Gymmkampaniet.
Och Per Ljungberg, innovationschef på Svensk Handel.
Kul att se dig, hur mår det?
Det är bra.
Fan, det finns platser kvar.
Helvet, var inte så jävla svenska.
Jag bara, ni vet, ska ni stå där borta i ett hörn typ och bara gömma er?
Fan, det är ingen stolar.
Där finns två stolar, de verkar trevliga.
Där finns en plats som man knö lite.
Men hörrni, fan, det händer ju sjukt mycket på e-handelsmarknaden just nu.
Alltså vi har ju Apoteas börsnotering imorgon, bara det, applåd för Apotea.
Fan, det här kommer vi förändra multiplarna för hela vår industri, sjukt kul.
Sen så har vi ju Hicap som köptes, en del av Hicap häromdagen.
Sen så har vi Our Legacy såklart, som sålde Ish, jag gissar 20 procent för ungefär en värdering på en miljard, gissar jag, till LVMH.
Alltså det har ju hänt mycket, det har typ hänt mer senaste månaden än under hela 2024.
Joel, kan inte du berätta lite hur mår e-handeln just nu?
Jag tror att den mår bra.
Det är min feeling, vi har haft relativt starka senaste fem, sex månader.
Vi slog all time high i augusti, september, otober och nu november.
Vi har egentligen inte ändrat marknadsföringen, utan det är bara för att jag gissar att folk är mer köpstarka.
Så jag tror att den mår bra.
Vi har ändå sällan köpt svare, vi har liksom inga impulsköp, utan det är ändå folk som har gått och tänkt på det.
Vad säger du Per, hur har e-handeln mått just i år?
Det har faktiskt börjat vända efter två helt plötsligt år där det var en negativ utveckling, vilket är helt absurd.
Jag har liksom följt e-handeln med e-barometern sedan 2007 och sedan ända fram till det.
Så det har varit 15-20% tillväxt varje år.
Det slog ju till som fas under pandemin, men sen har vi haft två tuffa år.
Men vi ser i år att det börjar närma sig den gamla tillväxttakten, 10% upp hit i år.
Vi följer det här varje månad, så november får vi reda på typ 19 december.
Indikationer man hör från folk i branschen, det man har läst är att vi säkert ligger där uppåt, 10-15% upp även i november.
Men är det någonting som du har varit förvånad över gällande 2024?
Eeeeh, egentligen inte.
Att det började vända var väl inte speciellt förvånande, utan jag har vissa fenomen som jag tycker borde komma hit, som inte har kommit hit.
Vi pratade om det lite kort innan här, jag var på ett föredrag på IAB, där vi pratade retail media som är gigantiskt stort i övriga världen, men fortfarande superlitet i Sverige, där det borde börja, för det är ju vinstmarginal på i princip 100%, där man har möjlighet att få upp det.
För jag menar, marginaler är ju för vissa i vår bransch väldigt tufft, har det ju varit ganska länge.
Där finns ju en enorm möjlighet.
Så det är förvånande att det inte har dykt upp än så länge.
När vi satt och snackade in i vårt rum där borta innan, så pratade vi om D2C, som först var så hett.
Det var börsnoteringar i staterna och det var jättevärderingar.
Sen bara följde ihop.
Nu så pratade du om en rapport där man ser att D2C är tillbaka lite grann.
Berätta lite om det.
När man tittar på market, det är säkert flera som har kollat in på deras 250-lista.
Det gäller ju 2023 till råga på allt.
Så ser man ju att de som har växt det snabbast, det är ju D2C-bolagen.
Det är sådana som Nordic Notes, NinePine, det är fortfarande Revolution Race.
De här bolagen som för några år sedan när man sa att D2C var stendött, att det nästan dömdes ut, det är ju fortfarande de som växer snabbast och de som har högst marginal.
Så gör man det rätt så finns det ju stora möjligheter.
Och Joel, hur gick Black Week för er då?
Jo men det gick bra.
Vad är bra?
Vi växte mer än förra året, men vi ändrade om lite grann.
Så fan hur långrandig vill du ha mig?
Väldigt, det här är nästan ett poddformat.
Men jag tror att kontexten är att om man scannar LinkedIn idag, den 4 december 2024, så ser du en rad posts om brands som säger att Blackweek har varit ett jätterekort.
Det känns som att november för första gången har varit starkt.
Det känns som att vi har lite medvind för engångsskuld.
Det har varit motvind många år.
Känner ni samma sak?
Ja, det var jävligt tydligt faktiskt.
Jag skrev också ett inlägg om det, men jag tror att vår snittmarginalsänkning var 3% under Blackweek.
Vi hade ändå 320% i ökad omsättning jämfört med en vanlig...
Vi har ju ganska tråkiga produkter, men det var hur mycket tryck som helst.
Alla har jobbat hela helger, vi har bara kört på.
Det krävdes ganska lite marginalsänkning för att folk faktiskt...
Eller lite rea för att folk faktiskt skulle köpa grejer.
Det kanske bara krävs att man skriver att det är rea.
Men i jämförelse med tidigare Black Weeks, förbereder ni er annorlunda den här gången eller var det en annan strategi just i år?
Ja men vi har testat lite olika.
Dels har vi bara skit i till Black Week och gett bort pengar istället.
Och sen så har vi gjort som alla andra och typ ja men vi tar fem procent, tio procent på allt.
Och i år så hade jag teorin att vi ska inte rea ut allting som är småplock, sådant som vi faktiskt inte tjänar några ordentliga pengar på.
Så i år så satte vi bara rea på större grejer eller dyrare grejer eller paket på det sättet och därför blev det en ganska liten andel av våra varor som vi faktiskt reade ut.
Men det bara drog med, det var som att folk har suttit och väntat för att se ifall de här dyra produkterna kommer sänkas lite grann.
Så vi kanske sänkte i snitt ja men sju, tio procent på de grejerna vi faktiskt sänkte på och det drev då jättemycket försäljning.
Och vi slapp packa 8000 paket, istället kunde vi packa dyra paket då.
Så det var väldigt trevligt.
Snyggt, ni är ju lagi kan man tillägga, så ni packar ju allting själva.
Ja exakt, ja jo jo, så får man ju tänka.
Jag tänker ju, timingen var helt perfekt på Black Week i år.
Det var ju många dagar efter löner som var liksom hela veckan låg ju nästan så.
Så jag tror att det kan ha spelat in också att det har gått väldigt bra.
Och att de signalerna är någonting helt annat.
Men det jag tyckte var intressant när jag läste Svea och prissjakt pressrelease, var ju att Prissjakt också sa just det du säger, att det var inte konsumenternas Black Week, utan det var e-handlarnas Black Week.
Det var inte samma stora rabatter men man har ändå sålt betydligt mer än tidigare.
Vilket ju är en superbra signal för hela e-handeln.
Vi såg även att snittårdvärdet gick upp jättehögt över Black Week, vilket är typ weird, men det visar också att folk passade på att köpa dyra grejer.
Det känns som att delvis har aktörerna blivit smartare och bättre, alltså brands och bolagen har blivit smartare och bättre på att hantera Black Week så att man inte bara rebort all sin marginal, utan att man optimerar för det som jag har tjottat om i min podd, GM3 såklart.
Å andra sidan så känns det också som att ekonomin bara är bättre, och i våra bolag är de mer mot Europa, Benelux, USA, det var bra, men det jag hör om svenska bolag, framförallt svenska ekonomin, så känns det extremt starkt.
Har du lite samma uppfattning?
Det är väl vår känsla om att det är, och jag tror det är alla positiva signaler som kommer till mitt med räntesänkningar, dubbel och sådana här saker.
Alltså det finns ju ett upphämt behov hos oss att vilja gå ut och shoppa tror jag.
Att man har hållit i äg men nu säger man att man kan börja handla.
Jag tror också många har ändå suttit inkl.
mig själv, som har vetat att jag ska köpa en del dyra vitvaror för min son flyttar hemifrån.
Jag har satt och väntat på den här veckan för man vet ju ändå att det kommer komma dåligt.
Och om man blickar på trender kan man säga att det har funnits några trender just under 2024 Joel?
Ja det är fel person.
Nej men det är liksom, hur lång tid tog det innan vi började prata om AI men det är väl klart att det är det som ändå har...
Ja, fick jag säga det?
Får jag säga?
Okej, AI.
Ja, då kan vi lägga ner det, eller hur klarar man det?
Om jag kommer undan med det svaret så AI, absolut.
Nej men ni egentligen, det effektiviserar ju grymt mycket, det går ju liksom inte att komma därifrån.
Och det är liksom ändå kul att börja titta på det här som börjar komma med Amazon Rufus med shoppingassistenter, att lycokopiera det liksom bara två veckor senare tycker jag var ganska häftigt.
Amazon går ut med en beta-version i februari, två veckor senare så kör Lycos in-version rakt ut på sin app.
Sedan kan man ju fundera på hur bra den är än så länge, men det är liksom det drar ju iväg åt ett förändrat beteende.
Och när man tittar på USA, jag läste någon nyhet häromdagen om, vad heter det här, perplexity eller något sånt där va?
Som ju egentligen både kan, inte bara i Amazon-plattformen utan det är också alla shoppify-butiker som den scannar av hur man har betett sig i.
Då börjar vi ju närma sig någonting att man har en personlig AI-assistent.
Man börjar fatta hur det kan bli.
Vilket i sin tur kommer ju ändra ganska mycket om ett par år.
Det fattade man inte år 1997 heller.
Vad ska man använda den här grejen internet till?
Vissa testar shopping och man testar massa olika saker.
Sedan är det självklart när man väl är där.
Det är lite det som är AI för mig just nu.
Man fattar inte riktigt hur man ska använda det.
Man sitter och betar testar use cases för det.
Joel, hur tillämpar ni AI internt?
Just nu har vi testat med typ Aden som kundkest och sånt där.
Vi stoppade den så den sade inte utan vi såg bara dialogen och sen stängde vi av den.
Det var inte riktigt där än.
Men givetvis använder vi det som alla andra i content såklart.
Men det är typ det som fyller sig som funktion för oss just nu om jag ska vara helt krasst.
Just det, och content i form av text och inte bild.
Ja exakt, vi byter lite bild när vi behöver fixa till lite grejer.
Ja men såklart, för det finns ju olika funktioner i Photoshop som också i AI och sådant.
Ja det är ju hur nördig man ska vara men det är jävligt mycket lättare att frilägga bilder liksom.
Om man kollar på 2025 och så kollar man bredare trender och jag gillar ju inte generellt uttrycka trender för det förändras ju, de stämmer inte alltid och det prioriteras högt för att det är en trend fast en trend behöver inte nödvändigtvis vara prioriterad liksom.
Men om man ska kolla på 2025, om man ska försöka måla ut det året, se till trender, vad ser du då?
Men en sak som man inte kan undvika, och nu kommer Joel tycka att jag är jobbig, att det är e-handlare som börjar öppna fysiska butiker, det ser vi ju.
När Kaja började öppna en jättestor butik på Oblivetegsgatan, hade någon sagt det för när de valde 2021 och vi utsåg dem till Sveriges bästa e-handelsesföretag på D-award, så var det ingen som trodde att de nån gång skulle öppna en fysisk butik.
Så det är ju ändå någon form, det är ju inte så heller, det är ju den här där man har fysiska butiken som är ett ställe att hänga i, för de räcker ju att gå in på NK och kolla in Kajas butik, liksom det står ju alltid 15-20 tonåringar i den där och hänger i butiken liksom.
Så att det är ju den delen, den går ju inte att runda, vi kommer ju att se mer av sånt utav varumärken.
Men där det inte är som en klassisk fysisk butiken, där det är snarare som ett communityskapande reklampelare där man driver varandra e-handeln och den fysiska butiken.
Så den trenden är ju helt, den har vi nog bara sett början på tror jag.
Och det här var ju intressant statistik att ta fram för svensk handel.
Vilka butiker läggs ner och vad ersätts de butikerna med?
Och det man ser lite grann, eller jag personligen utan statistik bakom det, är ju att DTCs tar ju alla nya eller tomma platser i ett mål av Scandinavia till exempel.
Så det känns ju som att direct consumer affärsmodellen nu utöver sin tidigare digitala affärsmodell också kör väldigt mycket butiker nu.
Ja men det var ju lite det vi sa att DTCs reviver men på ett nytt sätt kanske.
Precis, vad säger du om butiker Joel?
Jag vet att du älskar det här.
Det är för att vi pratade om detta innan.
Jag är lite sådär fan, måste detta alltid vara en grej.
På något sätt är det ju, alltid när folk säger vad är det jobbigaste med ett företag, då är det ju personal.
Det är ju det.
Även om man älskar sin personal, så är det ju personal som är jobbigast.
Startar du en butik, så måste du hantera personal, och du måste hantera schematläggning och grejer.
Är du en vanlig e-handel, så är det ett konstigt steg att börja med en butik.
Jag fattar att de här stora, Liko, Kajah och alla de här startar, men när man säger så, det är en trend.
Vi måste ha lite dynamik här, men när man säger att alla ska starta en e-handel, eller en butik, typ Nisse som säljer en modellflygplan, om han startar en butik för modellflygplan, det är ingen som, även om han är jättelönsam och det funkar jättebra, det är ingen som vill gå in och titta på den, nu var modellflygplan dålig.
Ja, men bara för att ni kan ha kontro och säga sportfisk i butiken på Söder, det är ju en stor grej.
Det är en e-handlare men många tycker att det är den bästa fysiska butiken i Stockholm, så det finns ju, men jag håller med dig.
Om man skulle säga såhär då, antalet butikslägen i Stockholm, har det ökat eller minskat de senaste åren?
Alltså är trenden nedåtgående.
Ja, men jag pratar om att det är e-handlare som öppnar kanske inte, det är ju inte som förr i tiden att jag är från Oskarshamn, ni inte fan kommer kajja upp när butiken är i Oskarshamn.
Ja, det är ju de här flagship-store som är en reklampelare snarare än en säljkanna.
Jag tror det är intressant det här.
Vi har två olika mindsets här med två olika perspektiv.
För att koppla det till bolagen vi nämnde i början, vi hade Apotea, det kommer vara den absolut viktigaste, starkaste börsnoteringen i närtid känns det som.
De är i ett marketplace.
Sen har vi Our Legacy, de säljer ju knappt online.
De säljer ju huvudsakligen till Holsey, det är det coolaste fashionbrandet just nu.
Sen snackade vi om Hiccups som är ett klassiskt D2C, Kaya style om man säger så.
Det är tre fundamentalt olika färsmodeller, alla tre är svinframgångsrika.
Per, hur kan det bli så här?
Finns det inget playbook?
Nej, och det var väl det vi menade om, att alla kan inte öppna en fysisk butik, utan det är inte det det handlar om att driva företag.
Det kändes som att någon kommer på en smart produkt, gör ett varumärke, sälj bara online och sen kör du en massa performance marketing så kommer du att lyckas.
Den tiden finns ju inte och så funkar det ju inte att vara, nu är inte jag entreprenör men så funkar det ju inte att vara entreprenör.
Så det finns ju ingen självklarhet.
Och sen så har vi såklart ett nine pine också som är performance drivet, en era när performance marketing är extremt konkurrensutsatt.
Alltså hela den här diskussionen gör mig förvirrad Joel, kan du beskriva för mig hur man skapar ett framgångsrikt brand i en digital miljö år 2025?
Ja, man får väl...
Alltså på något sätt, no offense mot Björn här, men ni snackar ju alltid brand.
Dels heter det varumärke, men dels...
Tack.
Dels blir det lite så här, fan vi som omsätter under 100 miljoner eller 200 miljoner, vad ska vi ens tänka på det just nu?
Är det inte lite halv weird att börja tänka branding och varumärke direkt från början?
Att bygga ett bra varumärke är egentligen att göra jävligt bra grejer under jävligt lång tid och att vara jävligt systematisk i vad du håller på med.
Sen om du öppnar butiker eller om du driver e-handel online eller om du fokuserar på snabba frakter eller låga priser eller vad du än gör, se till att göra det konsekvent, gör det under lång tid och du har ett starkt varumärke som folk vet vad de gör.
That's it.
Och det är väl lite det här som var lite härligt efter när det började gå dåligt för e-handeln och inte bara var tillväxt som gällde att, jag vet jag satt på D-Congress, det måste ha varit 21 och började helt plötsligt prata balansräkningar, elektronitet och allt sådana här saker som ingen hade suttit och pratat på på ett e-handels-event och det är ju liksom det och då tror jag det var väl det var väl också Paul Fischberg som pratade om att det bara handlar om operation, det går in och gör jobbet varje dag.
Det är så, det är ju då att bli en framgångsrik e-handlare, det liksom finns ingen enkel genverk.
Jag vet ju att ni Joel är ju extremt operationellt effektiva, alltså ni gör maskineriet extremt, extremt bra och det är ju liksom en del av hela affären och liksom bedrivare effektivt, det gör det riktigt vast så att säga.
Och sen förändrar det lite över tid, så då behöver man liksom fine-tune och förändra och justera sina idéer lite över tid och så där.
Men sen finns det ju också, alltså jag tycker det är svårt bara om man ska, går det att generalisera fler framgångsfaktorer på digitala bolag till nästa år?
Jo det är väl klart att det går, alltså det finns ju människor som är jätte jätte jätteduktiga på att skapa ett habegär eller som är duktiga på att skapa en känsla av att det här är någonting, det här är någonting, och det tycker jag inte man ska underskatta.
Det är också en strategi i sig, det är bara att jag inte är bra på den strategin.
Det enda jag är duktig på är den andra delen.
Jag är bra på såhär, det här funkar inte, hur ska vi få bort det?
That's it.
Varför, jag bara tycker att man ska inte hålla på att syssla med sådant som man inte ska syssla med.
Det låter Per som att man ska göra det man är bra på.
Det brukar ju vara en ganska bra avskott tycker jag, eller hur?
Men det är också det att det inte finns ett sätt att göra det på.
Jag tycker det är så jävla viktigt också.
Det här är poängen någonstans, att man ska identifiera det man gör bra och så ska man göra det ännu bättre och förbättra det konstant över tiden någonstans.
Om vi fortsätter blicka mot nästa år, Joel, vilken energi går vi in med in i år 2025?
Jag känner mig lite, jag får tänka vilket ord jag ska använda för att inte få massa skit här, men jag känner att vi ska in och vara lite småjobbigt, dominanta mot konkurrenter som har gått dåligt under den här perioden.
På vilket sätt?
Fast på ett kärleksfullt sätt.
Hur gör man det?
Återigen, utan att låta dryg, men ändå att kapitalism är en del av världen.
Så till exempel om du ser att en konkurrent som har gått dåligt har en storsäljare inom ett visst område eller kategori, så kan du gå in och krascha den kategorin om du har mycket pengar.
Eller du kan ju tapecera marknadsföring på ett område som du vet att din konkurrent tjänar mycket pengar på.
Jag bara säger att kapitalism är kapitalism.
Det finns ju många grejer man kan göra för att förstöra förmotståndet såklart och samtidigt ge kunden en bra upplevelse.
Ja men härligt.
Så kärleksfullt jag kunde hålla det utan att vara helt dryg.
Ja men spännande.
Per, du som har mer ett makroperspektiv.
Kapitalismen är väl makroperspektiv?
Sorry, fortsätt ut.
Exakt men om man kollar på 2025, vad kan vi förvänta oss i året?
Kan vi förvänta oss att den här medvinden ligger kvar?
Ja men jag tror det.
Det finns ju mycket, det finns ju många bitar att gå in och tala om där.
Alltså det som vi ser, det vi har sett om man bara ska ta det här med ur e-handel under det senaste året, att det har gått ifrån 66 procent som svarar att man e-handlar varje månad till att det nu har varit 71 varje månad under hela det här året.
Så det är fler och fler som börjar gå till nätet igen.
Det vi samtidigt ser är ju att fler går till utländska aktörer.
Så att det är liksom, jag kan inte sitta här från Svenska Handel och inte nämna tema och se in liksom.
Och det är klart att de kommer fortsätta att ta delar för de är ju liksom, pris kommer fortfarande vara en viktig faktor.
Jag tror ju att vi är i en värld där man är, att det alltid är så jävla polariserat just nu.
Det är liksom, det är liksom antingen det ena eller det andra, även om vi säger att det inte finns en modell, så är antingen så är det jättemycket lågpris, eller så är det premiumvarumärken, eller så är det second hand och någon form av den som i och för sig kan ha ett prisaspekt, men har också en någon form av premiumdel som går jävligt bra för de som säljer premium second hand.
Så att det är ju, jag tror att vi fortsätter, precis som samhället i stort med Trump och allting är grymt polariserade, så är konsumenterna också grymt polariserade, vilket gör att det finns utrymme både att få vara liksom, liksom lågt pris och ha fokus på dem, men också att vara ett premiumsevarimärke.
Och jag tror att vi kommer fortsätta att se att det finns inte en lösning, utan att det finns väldigt många olika lösningar.
Men finns det vissa segment som går extra bra?
Det vi har pratat om, det är en av dem, apoteksvaror har gått bra ända sedan pandemin och fortsätter att ticka på.
Och vi kommer knappast få se Pär Schwädsson öppna en fysisk butik, om vi ska prata fysiska butiker igen liksom.
Så dead cementet har gått skitbra.
Tobak har gått löjligt bra det senaste året.
Vi ser ju att Heipp kommer som tredje största e-handelsbolaget i Sverige just nu i den här listan jag pratade om.
Alltså snusbolaget som det heter utåt.
Sedan ser vi att skönhet har också fortsatt, ligger ganska nära apoteksvaror.
Sedan har vi faktiskt också börjat se att möbler och det här har börjat tissa upp efter att vi har haft det jävligt jobbigt några år.
Hur går sport och fritida?
Den ligger av, eller hur kan du prata om inrush någon gång, eller hur?
Nej men den puffar ju på någonstans i mellanskiktet.
Det är liksom inte, det är varken bu eller bä.
Det är väl det här där det egentligen mode också har legat.
Du kan fråga XXL och Decathlon om de håller med.
Ja men det finns väl vissa som går bra, eller hur?
Med några stora som har fysisk butiker, det är jobbigt eller?
Joel hur tänker du ur ett 5-10 års perspektiv?
Jag vet att du är väldigt långsiktig i ditt bolag.
Du tänker liksom inte exit, du tänker inte riskkapital, du tänker lönsamhet och nitiskt byggande över lång tid.
Vad tror du, vi kan förvänta oss, ska vi bara förvänta oss 10% per år kommande tio åren?
Eller vad tänker du?
Nej jag är inte jätteoptimistisk för 2025.
Jag vet att man ska vara lite halv-hype i, men jag tänker att alla förväntar...
Så som jag ser på våra siffror, så har vi till exempel sett att delbetalningar har blivit vanligare.
Vi har nästan aldrig delbetalningar, men det har blivit vanligare.
Så min feeling är att många nu handlar för att de tänker att nu ska det bli bra.
Inte att det faktiskt är bra, för om jag kollar på våra lån, så är de fortfarande inte särskilt roliga liksom.
Men vi tror, ah nu kom det en dubbelsänkning, fan det är 0,5, vad ska vi göra med den?
Vi är fortfarande panka liksom.
Jag menar att så jävla bra är det inte ännu, och det är ganska mycket oroligheter som håller på.
Det krävs ganska lite för att det ska hända någonting.
Så det är lite farligt att bara tänka att nu har det vänt, och nu kommer 2025, nu ska jag helt plötsligt gå guld och gröna skogar, och sen kommer det gå uppåt här i tio år till.
Men saker är ju inte svarta eller vita, och det är också svårt att sätta fingre på vart man befinner sig när man befinner sig i nutiden.
Men jag har lite branschskvaller vi kan filosofera runt.
Åra 2026 vet att det finns en massa fonder som har investerat i en massa e-handelsbolag, och de måste sälja i stort sett rubbet det året.
Vi ser nu Apoteas börsnotering, vi ser att IPO-marknaden börjar komma igång igen, och sen ser vi att det sker transaktioner, hicka på liknande på troligtvis okej nivåer, säkert ökan över tid.
Sen ser vi att 2026-2027 börjar alla riskkapitalägda bolagen tvingas att röra på sig då.
Vad händer då, Per?
Det är spännande, du svarar nästan där emellan i dina någonstans.
Nej men det är en jättebra fråga.
Jag är inte heller så att jag säger att allting är guld och gröna skogar nästa år, det är det absolut inte, det är en tuff tid.
Men ändå får du säga, vi har ju också i och för sig att vi har lite skattesänkningar och så där, så det finns ju lite incitament för att få mer pengar i plånboken som förhoppningsvis inte bara sparas.
Men det är ju, ja vad händer då, vad tror du Björn?
Jag kastar tillbaka.
Härligt.
Jag tror att det kommer sakta men säkert förbättras och utan att vi har märkt det, pang kommer vi att befinna oss i en ny högkonja kanske 2028-2029.
Det sker i de här cyklarna, cyklarna pågår i var sjunde till tionde år historiskt.
Så det är antagligen något sådant som jag skulle gissa.
Skulle man titta på det historiskt så är det ju så.
Jag kommer ihåg att det var senast var det en podd där du sa, du som varit med 2008, då kände jag mig som en pensionär, jag var med i 1999 också, eller 2001.
I det raset efter dotcom-perioden.
Men det är ju som du säger, det var ju det som var den stora chocken 2020.
Det var ju många inom EU-handeln som aldrig varit med om någonting som bara var neråt helt plötsligt.
Så det är väl rimligt att om vi nu säger att det började gå ner där, efter pandemin och allting, så finns det väl, om man nu ska titta på historien och ekonomisk historia, så borde det ju börja vända någonstans då.
Å andra sidan så är vi i en världsläge där man inte vet vad händer med Trump, vad händer med Tullar, vad händer med världshandeln och allt det här.
Så det är väl lite som jag brukar säga, att den som lärt sig att leva med ovisshet har läst sig det största i livet.
Det är väl det vi får fortsätta att leva med.
Det är lite kopplat till min nästa fråga till Joel.
Du har ju kört bolaget, hur många år nu?
2016 köpte jag.
Precis, du har ju kört snart tio år och då har du varit med om minst en lågkonjunktur och minst en covid-högkonjunktur e-handelshype.
Har du liksom byggt bolaget annorlunda i bra tider, kontra i dåliga tider?
Nej, det skulle jag inte säga.
Jag är som sagt jättelångsiktig i detta.
Min tanke är att göra detta tills jag dör, hopp för det är förhoppningsvis långt bort.
Och då...
Nej, jag har inget incitament att göra någonting annat än att tuffa på i det tempo jag kan tuffa på.
Så försöker jag bara hantera det på bästa sätt.
Jag har en plan som jag tycker är bra.
Så länge den inte blir motbevisad så kommer jag att köra på.
Ser du att andra har byggt sina bolag annorlunda i högkonjor, kontra lågkonjor?
Ja, absolut.
På vilket sätt?
Det är ett helt annat sätt hur man marknadsför, vad man godkänner för förluster, hur man tänker kring att dela ägande kanske med andra att ta in pengar, att inte ta in pengar, vad man satsar på, om man kan satsa på fasta avgifter eller fasta kostnader eller inte fasta kostnader eller bara jobba rörligt.
Det är jättetydligt.
Hade jag byggt bolaget för att gå bra under corona så hade jag givetvis gjort på ett helt annat sätt.
Och så motsvarande då.
Per, du sa att du var med sen 1999 och då hade vi IT-kraschen när bud.com och sen kom finanskrisen och sen kom corona.
Och nu är vi någonstans i någon slags smälla land där ingen riktigt vet om det går uppåt eller neråt.
Men det känns som att det börjar gå uppåt.
Kan du se att man kan dra några lärdomar från bra tider, dåliga tider och hur bolag agerar?
Hur bygger man någonting långsiktigt och beständigt trots upp-
och nedgångarna?
Vi har väl ett levande exempel bredvid oss.
Att tänka på det hela tiden och inte tänka i de här kortsiktiga eller att man liksom glömmer historiken, för det är väl lite det många gjorde när man också sa att vi kan gå med vinst i morgon.
De här bolagen som sa det kunde ju inte riktigt gå med vinst i morgon och de finns ju ofta inte kvar idag tänkte jag säga.
Jag kan bara tänka på en grej som jag tycker är den absolut viktigaste.
Det är typ ha inte så mycket fasta kostnader.
Jag tycker att man kan vara väldigt generös.
Vi ska till Tyskland hela företaget här om några månader och då bjuder vi med alla från lagret till kunden och bara fuck it, ta in på bra hotell, sup, gör fast på ett företagsmässigt sätt ni vet.
Men så har de frågat till exempel kan vi få ha en fruktkorg varannan vecka?
Nej det får ni inte för det är 399 spänn i fast kostnad.
Och det är faktiskt skillnad, det kan låta som ett jättelöjligt exempel.
Eller till exempel städning har vi inte, utan det måste vi fråga om vi kan ha städning.
För att tänka om vi inte har pengar.
Jag vill inte vara bunden på några fasta kostnader som vi inte kan använda.
Och jag tycker att det är en viktig punkt som folk glömmer.
Men låt oss prata lite om fasta kostnader då.
Till exempel Paul Fishbein på Revolution Race.
Jag vet att han är sjukt nitty gritty om siffrorna, vad man ska addera till sin PNL och så vidare.
Och så finns det Nine Pines som gör det extremt effektivt.
De är extremt få personer per omsättningskrona.
Det finns ju någonting i den här effektiviteten.
Finns det ett samband där per, de som klarar sig att bygga någonting långsiktigt, att de är nitty gritty med fasta kostnader?
Ja, definitivt.
Det tycker jag vi har sett, det är väl ganska tydligt tycker jag.
Det är ju som är lite det sa, de här som bara drog på och byggde upp för tillväxt, och är lite elakt för att sälja, så gör de exit.
De har ju inte lyckats vända.
Inte många av dem i alla fall, vad jag vet.
Det är ju liksom att ha koll på, jag tror det är precis det, att ha koll på sina kostnader liksom.
Och ibland kan det bli att man ger folk skit som gör så.
Det är ju inte skit.
De har ju sålt, de har gjort en bra exit, de har gjort det de skulle göra.
All cred.
Jag menar, ibland blir det som att man ställer dem här mot varandra, varför ska man ställa dem mot varandra?
Om det är din plan och du gjorde den, bra jobbat.
Och olika affärsmodeller kräver ju olika saker.
Vi pratar om Aureliqus i Hållseltunga, så har vi Hicca, Appetit to See, så har vi andra som startar i massa fysiska butiker.
Det krävs ju olika saker av PNL för att göra olika saker.
Låt oss fokusera på trenden som du snackade om Pär, det vill säga butiksetableringar.
Det här är ju sjukt svårt och det kostar mycket att hitta location, renovera location, anställa personer och så vidare.
Joel, är det därför, är du för snån för butiker?
Jag tycker när du säger så här, det kostar mycket, det är sjukt svårt.
Det känns som att det här med butiksetablering är en trend som fastighetsägarna försöker sprida ut i händelsbranschen för att vi ska ta över.
Sådär lägen som ingen vill ha.
Men...
Jag vet inte vilka de här är som du pratar om, Hiccup eller det andra företaget.
Jag kan ingenting om någonting som inte har med min bransch att göra, mina siffror och våran värld.
Och skulle vi gå in i butik så är det som att jag måste lära mig till kompetensområde.
Det är inte min nisch, varför ska jag in där och grotta?
Det är egentligen bara det det handlar om.
Vi har inte tid att bli bäst på det.
Per, du har ju snackat om äkta omnikanalsstrategier.
Vad menar du med det?
Det är väl egentligen de här.
Det är väl lite gärna att man kan se, det är snarare de som kommer från det fysiska hållet som har lyckats få ihop det till det digitala och som gör det bra och som får ihop det i att man numera, jag kommer ihåg att jag skulle gå och köpa någon, hämta ut någonting på, nu ska jag inte, det är ett stort möbelvaruhus som säljer vissa, inte det största utan ett annat.
Där man liksom sa nej det där är e-handel, det kan du inte göra där, det måste du göra på måndag när vi öppnar den biten, då det var i deras lördags butik.
Så såg det ut för tre, fyra år sedan men det gör det inte på riktigt samma sak i ett sätt idag.
Det är liksom, man har jobbat med olika AI-verktyg, man har jobbat med RFI, man vet vad man har i lager och så där.
Men då är det ju de stora, då är det ju snarare de som går ifrån fysiskt butik som har blivit bättre på det digitala och som tvingades bli det under pandemin om man ska vara lite hårt dragen liksom.
De investerade mycket i det idag och som idag är ganska bra på e-handel också.
De har fått ihop det där och har butikerna som lager men då är det ju en annan typ av affärsmodell för då har de ju börjat i retail och fysisk handel och kan det och har fått snarare lära sig e-handel.
Det är där jag tycker att det finns en del som gör det här ganska bra.
Claes Oleson Lindexson tycker jag gör det riktigt riktigt bra idag.
Exakt och då tänker jag att det finns en möjlighet i det där.
Alltså såklart just nu finns det ett klimat där lokalen är ganska tillgänglig.
Alltså de som kan fysisk butiksetablering.
Det är nog en ganska bra grej att kunna i dagens klimat.
Det lär ju säkert förbrändas Down the Road.
Men så tänker jag liksom, det finns ju några som kan kanske börja dit och se först och sen så lär de sig fysiskt butiksetablering och de lär sig det tredje affärsmodellen wholesale.
Alltså att man kombinerar de här och inte bara kombinerar dem utan man också exekverar dem väl.
Joel, skulle du kunna lära dig, du har bara 24 timmar per dygn, du har ett heltidsjobb som tar liksom 60-70 timmar i veckan iså ja, skulle du ha kapacitet att lära dig ett wholesale parallellt vid befintliga affärsmodellen?
Det är klart att man kan lära sig men jag tror inte alla affärsmodeller lämpar sig för det.
Dels om du skulle lagerhålla våra produkter i en butik så skulle det vara helt meningslöst eftersom bara golv tar 400 kvadrat och det är ingen som går dit för att köpa golv.
Det är inte rimligt men om vi tar ett av dina, du nämner ibland Axel Arigato, om vi nu ska prata om, vad sa du?
Hela tiden.
Då är det ju ändå ett varumärke som lämpar sig väl för tre grejer och där de faktiskt förstärker varandras områden och det blir en grej.
Då har du en affärsmodell och ett bolag som verkligen är gjort för det.
Då är det klart du ska göra det men våran affärsmodell är inte gjord för det.
Vi har inte den marginalen, vi har inte den sortens produkter, det blir en konstig logistik, det hade inte gått runt.
Om du har affärsmodellen för dig, klart som fan du ska göra det, det är ju skitbra, då kan du bli stor på riktigt.
Det är ju skillnad där, jag vill komma ihåg att du intervjuade Albin där när vi hade dem på DO.
War och sa att fyra gånger ni är e-handlare, han blev upprött till slut för ingen e-handlare vid lifestyle brand.
Men de har ju en annan grej, de här varumärkena som ser butiken som en plats där de bygger varumärken, lika mycket som de säljer.
Så det är en annan affär än en klassisk e-handel naturligtvis.
Exakt, det är som en extension av brandet och det blir ett vardagsrum snarare än butik och så råkar folk handla i deras vardagsrum.
Exakt, eller på nätet efter att ha hängt i deras vardagsrum.
Och så finns det tydliga synergier där att man har en fysisk butik och så ökar hela performance i närområdet och så vidare.
Om vi ska ta Axel Arigato, eftersom nu hamnar det, det får handla om dem, fuck it, all credit till dem.
Men jag vet också att du nämnde att de har sina skor på flygplatser och liknande.
Bara för att visa hur sjukt det hade varit.
Om vi ställer upp en träningsbänk på Arlanda så är det ju ingen som...
Alltså det ger ju ingenting till någon.
Förutom klossfittare.
Som tar av sig tröjan och lägger sig där och rättar.
Tar en selfie så.
Okej, när jag var med.
Jag var med att vissa lämpar det sig för och vissa gör det inte.
Jag fattar, men jag tror jag nämnde det för att det finns ju ett känt svenskt kladdesvarumärke som har fyra bokstäver, jag ska inte säga det snabbt.
Och de har ju alla de här benen och de blöder ju pengar.
De har ju supertuft finansiellt.
Jag tänker att det finns också en risk i den här splittningen av affärsmodell, att man inte specialiserar sig.
Att man gör allt samtidigt.
Ser du?
Om jag ser en risk i det?
Ja det ser jag väl en risk i.
Mycket bra svar, låt oss snacka om ett topic till och sen vill jag avsluta med lite snabba frågor.
Det här topiket är såklart det vi nästan började med AI.
Alla har pratat om det här med Joel.
I kanske två år sedan Shadki Pt gick live och man pratade om att det här skulle förändra allt.
Alla tillvägångsrätt, om inte du lär dig att tillämpa det här i ditt jobb så kommer du att vara arbetslös om typ tre år.
Varje gång det kommer en ny version av Shadki Pt så hypas du sig att den ska vara helt insane och så använder man den och ser det typ ingen skillnad.
Hur ser ni på AI, kan ni börja där Per, vad gör AI med retail och låt oss inte snacka 2025, för det kommer säkert inte hända så mycket, men låt oss snacka 2030, 2040.
Om vi ska 2040, det är 15 år, går man 15 år bakåt i tiden så är det en helt annan värld.
Nu går det snabbare.
Jag tycker att det är lite som, när QR-koden kom, när man skulle scanna en QR-kod så såg man det till reklamblad, det var ungefär det man gjorde.
Idag använder man QR-koder överallt och det ska vara QR-koder för att göra digitala produktpass och spåra.
Det dröjer ju alltid när det kommer en ny teknik som alla snackar om.
Så finns det ju alltid en period då det kanske går tillbaka lite och sedan, nu tror jag inte det går tillbaka, men att det går lite sakta det än att det bara revolutionerar allt imorgon.
Men om vi nu ser en 10-15 år så tror jag att det kommer att vi kommer att handla på ett helt annat sätt än vi gör idag.
Alltså det kommer bli en annan grej.
Det kommer inte vara så att du surfar in lika mycket på en site kanske för att titta och välja de här så trevliga de shoppar jag utan jag tror att du kommer jobba mycket mer av din egen assistent.
Men det blir ju science fiction för vad vet jag, det kanske är något helt annat som kommer om tre år som vi inte vet idag.
Om man snackar ju om att kortsiktigt så överskattar man alltid hur stor impacten ska vara och långsiktigt så underskattar man alltid hur stor impacten kommer att bli.
Men liksom låt oss vara superkonkreta Joel du som sitter och nöter huvudet i en laptop liksom 60 timmar i veckan.
Vad tror du om AI 2025, 2030 och 2040?
Jag tror att på ett eller annat sätt så kommer AI inkluderas i sök som är våran stora kanal, oavsett hur du vill se det.
Jag tror att man behöver tänka om Google hade kunnat täcka allt i världen.
Hur hade vi behövt förhålla oss till det då och hur hade vi behövt agera?
Vi pratade lite löst om det innan, men jag tror att när vi i framtiden ska synas på AI så kommer den ge ett förslag och den kommer känna av om du är rik eller fattig, tycker du om det här eller det här, bor du här eller här.
Och så får du ett förslag och sen kommer du inte säga ge mig tio nya förslag utan du kommer säga jag vill ha den lite större, jag vill ha den lite mindre, jag vill ha den lite flasher, lite mer på det sättet.
Allt kommer att handla om attribution, alltså hur du framställer dina produkter och hur de kan visas upp, hur de kan tolkas och liknande.
Allting kommer att handlas om att bli the preferred brand som visas upp i första läget.
För att då kanske de dessutom gör att de swipar inte på andra utan de swipar bara på din butik.
Det finns en anledning till att jag trots att, men fan jag är inte den bästa advokaten för gymkompaniet men jag sitter ju här och pratar för att då får vi press någonstans, vi syns någonstans, det visar att vi är ett credible source.
Om tio år kanske det är jätteviktigt att vi har 900 artiklar om gymkompaniet.
För det visar att vi har funnits med länge, vi är inte på loss att vi är påhittat dropship brand som Breakit skriver om hela tiden.
Och då vågar AI visa oss.
Och man måste finnas med på olika recensionssajter, man måste finnas med på olika, jag bara menar att, säger poddar till exempel, varför skulle den inte granska igenom allt ljud, varför skulle den inte granska igenom alla filmer, vi pratar om tio år, det är klart som fan den kommer göra det.
Då måste vi vara med i massa poddar, vi måste ha en egen podd om man nu ska välja.
Alltså så här, det är klart du måste pusha ut och se till att det finns, annars finns det inte.
Jag tror att det är mycket svårare att komma upp från ingenting om tio år.
Att man finns digitalt, för det är det som är sökbart.
Så du sitter här för att skapa framtida SEO-legitimitet gentemot framtida AI-tekniker.
Jag tror ingen här i rummet känner, fan Joel vill jag handla gymutrustning av idag, utan jag är en skum kille.
Men det kommer att stå att han var på junis event och det var gymkompaniets.
All cred en punkt upp.
Jag tror också att det här med att varumärket kommer att öka i betydelsen också.
För det är ändå så att när du väl står där, det räcker ju idag om du går in och söker något på prisjakt.
Jag väljer inte den som jag inte har en aning om vilka det är, utan jag väljer den som kostar 20 kronor mer med ett känt varumärke.
Det är klart att det där av kommer finnas den typen av vikten av att ha ett starkt varumärke och finnas med i sådana här poddar, men också finnas i den fysiska världen av just den anledningen.
Spännande hörrni, nu ska vi avsluta med några korta frågor.
Vi börjar med den första.
Per, har på TIA köpt eller sälj?
Jag har inte tecknat mig men köpt.
Du har ju köpt Joel.
Han har ju tecknat så det ska inte ge fråga.
Om ni fick ge ett tips till e-handlare vardag, vad skulle det tipset vara?
Vi börjar med Joel.
Jag tycker att när man räknar vinster och förluster så räknar man lite basic.
Man tänker typ, här har jag köpt en vara för 100 spänn, den har 50% marginal, jag har 50 spänn kvar, det kostar 20 spänn i frakt, jag tar bort 20, jag har 30 spänn kvar att använda på marknadsföring.
Det funkar inte så.
Det kommer att komma skitgrejer, det kommer att komma returer, det kommer att komma saker som går sönder, det kommer att komma packkostnader som du inte har räknat med.
Jag skulle säga att en av de största misstagen som folk gör är att de glömmer massa utgifter som finns, som är rörliga men som man inte tänker på för att de inte passar in i någonting.
Så det tror jag många missar, att de behöver en marginal som är lite större än vad de tänker för att det finns en utgift som de inte visste om.
Bra tips, du får samma fråga här för att den är så viktig.
Ett tips e-handlare.
Det är lite problemet att det ska man då, då blir det väldigt beroende vad det är för typ av aktör, så jag tycker att vi räcker med Joels fantastiska tips.
Håll koll på plus och minus.
Då tar vi höjd för att ha bra marginal.
Då tar vi såklart en stor makrofråga till dig.
Vart är e-handeln om tio år?
Det blir ju lite science fiction, men jag tror ju lite det vi pratade om, att det är mer det vi var inne på, att det är viktigare.
Jag tror att det är viktigt med varumärke, jag tror det är viktigt med allt det som Joel pratade om, att komma högt upp i de här assistenterna och på något sätt jobba med det.
För jag tror att e-handeln kommer att handla om hur vi shoppar kommer att se helt annorlunda ut och det förändrar sättet att driva e-handel.
Spännande och Joel, vilket misstag ser du att entreprenörer oftast begår när de driver sina bolag?
Jag fastnar lite, får jag svara på Per Skåga också?
Jag bara tänkte att det blir lite som att man tänker att eftersom AI går framåt, då måste man satsa jättemycket på AI för att sticka ut.
Men jag tror att det kommer bli ännu mer viktigt att jobba med processer för att det är egentligen det som gör att du kommer bli lämpligt för AI och synas i AI.
Om AI vet att du hanterar allting, du har allting upplagt på rätt sätt, allting blir korrekt, då har du typ gjort en textbok AI-kompatibel verksamhet.
Så att man ska vara tråkigare än vad man tänker.
Vi tänker så att man ska synas överallt.
Jag ska vara med i Vogue, jag vet inte vad bra tidningar heter.
Men liksom, nej, du ska ha back to basic igen, det är det som kommer premieras, tror jag.
Vad var den andra frågan?
Den andra frågan var misstag som de flesta entreprenörerna begår.
De har kanske inte träckligt med tålamod.
Man har någon sorts inställning, både att det ska gå över, eller att det ska gå bra, eller att det ska gå dåligt, man tänker att det ska förändras på något sätt, och det gör det typ inte, utan första året är det ganska tufft, tredje året är det ganska tufft, när de omsätter 50 miljoner är det ganska tufft, 100 miljoner är ganska tufft, alltså det är skit på olika sätt.
Fast det är kul, annars kan man inte göra det, men om man inte tycker om det så gör det inte, för det kommer inte att vara annorlunda om tre år.
Jättebra tips, och Per får dagens sista fråga.
Om du ska sätta finger på några egenskaper eller färdigheter som är entreprenörer och ledare för digitala retailbolag ska ha och bör ha, vad skulle det vara?
Åh, vilken svår fråga.
Joel är väl ett utverkande exempel.
Jag är inte entreprenör.
Att ha koll på kostnaderna och operation, och inte haka på för mycket sådana här trender som jag talar om, utan ha koll på sin business.
Jättebra.
Hörrni, jättetack för att ni kom hit idag.
En varm applåd för Per och Joel.
Det är ju så här att kvällen inte är över riktigt än, utan för er som är här på plats så kommer vi att servera massa vin, massa bärs, massa najs.
Det kommer finnas massa snacks, mat och dryck.
Så stanna kvar.
Återigen, jättetack för att ni tog er hit och vi hörs snart igen.
Hej!